Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for a Monday.
The isn't may sexist today,
May 6th.
I have no idea.
I'm here with Joe Bartnick.
Joey B what's going on?
Oh,
just children out in Israel,
man.
It's a,
it's insane dude.
It's like we were in Europe for a week and it's like Europe's kind of like,
it's like,
it's like in America,
but it's different.
It's cool.
Everyone's really nice.
And then like as we were landing,
I see you guy watch your videos are like bombs going off an antiaircraft.
Then like we landed,
we're in Israel.
Where in Israel it's like,
dude,
I'll let you explain it.
We had the,
we just had the most boss airport experience ever.
Oh yeah.
When we landed here,
first of all,
thank God I don't watch the news because as always,
I guess things that are a little,
uh,
what do they call it?
It's,
I see little chippy.
Thanks again.
A little chip in here or up or off sticks
over here itself.
Yeah.
We got to the airport and uh,
no,
well I'll do that.
I don't know why we're doing this.
We're doing this like backwards.
We were in fucking Amsterdam the night before and went to a bar and smoked a
joint where they also serve milkshakes.
So I,
I was sitting there like,
I don't like,
I'm not big on fucking smoking weed.
I don't even think I do it right or I don't even realize when I'm high or
whatever.
There's like this is a body high.
Like this just gets you fucking right side high.
I don't understand.
Like,
dude,
you ain't got shit.
You were so high.
You ordered a strawberry milkshake and then you thought it was vanilla and then
you'd debated it and then you thought it was vanilla until about halfway down.
You Go.
No,
it's really strawberries.
Well
cause it was so subtle,
but the thing was white.
It was the color of vanilla.
It's rubbery shake where I'm from is fucking red or pinkish.
And I got the thing and I was sipping it.
You know what it was?
It was like the frozen Glob of it was where all the strawberry ones.
So when I got to the end,
you know,
when you get to the sort of the,
uh,
the glacier part of the milkshake,
I was like,
oh,
this does have some strawberry in it.
It literally did have a flake of red in it though,
you know,
it was funny,
was fucking everybody and there was smoking and was high.
And then we all got up to the counter where like we say to the lady there like,
did you charge us yet?
And she's like,
oh no.
She's like,
figure it out.
I'm like,
this is no way to run a business.
But,
um,
the shows have been great.
And uh,
Joel,
I gotta I gotta give you like,
I've never seen anybody fucking go,
come over here.
I've seen in a lot of American comics,
I've talked to a lot of American comics are all like,
I think,
and again,
my stop,
what do I talk about or what are you any advice and blah,
blah,
blah.
I remember [inaudible] was like,
he was like going like,
dude,
I know I'm going to take a couple of bad ones but I'm going to figure this out.
And um,
you know,
he had to make adjustments to make adjustments.
You're the only game you just came over here and you were Joe Barton.
You walked on stage fucking murdered in Iceland,
Iceland,
Iceland and then a right to the top.
Just like this guy's,
yeah,
you're as confident at all.
We all were here.
It took me 10 years to get where the hell you're at right now.
So you've been fucking killing everywhere.
Well thank you.
But uh,
basically wells,
Megan into bill
cause I got,
I got to be confident with them.
I know,
but you don't need it
that you didn't even doubt them.
That's amazing.
I think it's a great thing.
I think it's scarier to be,
and just like a,
you know,
in a little club in Hollywood that are like,
or somewhere,
I don't know,
there's 3000 people.
Some of them are going to laugh,
hopefully.
Right.
Your family for your friends are the best dude.
How,
how great.
Where they really,
I mean they,
it was really great shows.
Yeah.
You know,
you've seen the,
you've seen,
you really loved Helsinki,
man.
That was useful,
but,
huh?
Helsinki.
Yeah.
You know what's winning?
Oslo looks like Pittsburgh,
but it's funny.
We were walking through and Bajrang the booker.
Great Dude with sue super cigars.
It was like the or,
or Shanti.
His buddy works with them.
Another great dude.
He's like,
this is the toughest part of Oslo.
It looked like,
it looked like it looked like a Beverly hills.
Yeah.
Just seemed like there was a couple of drunks.
It's weird,
you know that Scandinavian language update you when people do yell at it,
does all of that shit.
I'll sound like a Nazi guard to me.
I'm like,
AH,
fuck it.
Starting again.
But Helsinki was,
Helsinki was awesome.
I went down to the dog,
get up like five in the morning and walked in like a freezing rain.
It really was.
It really was awesome.
I had a meat pie.
I felt like Anthony Bordain like the street talking to the dock workers.
That was fun.
Uh,
got to hang out late night in Stockholm with some friends drink til it closed
down Stockholm.
That was great.
Only rat I saw the whole time and sweet.
Literally,
literally a rat.
Marshawn knows Swedish women are tough.
What?
Right between her legs,
like not that this is the other things.
A radical.
I was,
I was gonna say like,
yeah,
I'm just walking through a hotel,
walked between and I want to be able to handle that.
Yeah.
It was pretty tough but fun.
I tell you,
I think Iceland was the craziest though.
Iceland was nuts.
There was no dogs.
It scared the shit out of me.
I'm like,
there's no dogs when they do with the dogs.
I'm a dog.
I've been painting like every dog in Europe in the last thing we were so cut to,
we went to leave.
I was on the Baltic Sea or the Adrian,
whatever.
C was freezing in Helsinki last night.
Perfect.
Whether we're in Israel,
smoking,
smuggling,
the best steak ever.
What
would fun?
I don't even know what that was.
A Baltic seas between Sweden and Finland,
but I don't know what that body of water is.
Let me look this up here.
I think I got a map here.
I was trying to figure out all of this shit.
What?
See what the fuck did I just do?
What in God's name just happened?
Do you know somebody?
I got a duff mckagan is going to be doing my podcast,
which I can't believe so they send me a link to his new fucking hour when I
sweat.
It just never works.
It never fucking works.
I sweat.
I think computers that they like,
they don't like me.
Well like last night I always,
I always watched the hockey games.
It's like okay we're gonna Watch the hockey game doing work.
They have to Redo your password 30 times.
The wifi goes nuts here at the y,
you know,
is is amazing.
Wifi is every well that is all the Baltic Sea.
It is on the bumper.
We just circled the Baltic.
Yeah,
we circled the Baltic.
You know what I actually we've been looking up sees cause I was claiming the
Mediterranean was the biggest and I feel the greatest
of all the C's.
I like all the features of the season.
Okay.
Duke haters.
I was like you haven't seen in Gaming Carolina.
It was,
you know it was neat though.
Like what?
Like you know like if you land like,
so you find the Pittsburgh,
you you'll see like Cleveland,
New York,
Washington DC.
Literally when we landed in Tel Aviv,
Tel Aviv,
the cities where bay route Cairo and Alexandria,
I don't know.
I don't know if we were like high enough up.
I think we were seeing now when we were coming in though,
cause they see how there's bay route.
It was like,
dude look at that on the map,
you know,
fucking far away.
There's only so many cities they going to show.
You know,
if you're like far enough up,
you see like Dallas when you're in the middle of [inaudible] you're talking
about when I was taking the pictures when we were on final coming in.
Well yeah.
Well,
you know how like the computers they show you like on the screen on the odd,
yeah.
I,
let's say I saw Lebanon,
I thought you don't test what you were saying?
No,
I'm saying like they showed,
you know,
like approaching where you see like the screen.
Yeah,
that was her job.
You'd be coming in right over like the end of,
I don't know if the most eastern part,
obviously the Mediterranean Sea and then just seeing that coast and it's just
like Jesus Christ once we're in Israel.
So then we land right.
And uh,
through the only other person I ever saw get this fucking pocket.
I saw Ben Affleck was on my flight one time,
right.
I got on the plane,
he was already on the plane,
you know,
and then when they got off and I was sitting there going like,
wow,
this guy's just going to get off this case.
Like a huge,
huge,
huge star and he's going to get mobbed.
The yes,
no security person.
And when he got off the plane,
he just went right down with the bags where they bring like,
you know,
50.
You had to check your carry on cause there was no more overhead space.
He went down that way and they just whisked him away to visit amazing life.
And uh,
when we got to uh,
Israel,
they did that.
They gave us the same treatment.
I felt like an asshole.
They walked her us around,
all those people standing in line.
I thought somebody was going to say something,
I'd throw something at us.
And uh,
it was hilarious.
I saw this big fat Jewish dude who I swear to God look like Joe to Rosa.
Like there was something about his eyes and it was fucking hilarious.
Um,
it was like Ellis island that we skipped.
Yeah.
Even the security line,
it was like a massive humanity do we just skipped,
but they,
yeah,
they,
I thought we were going right to the hotel.
Like we to go back into the airport,
we used to give everybody by car.
Yeah.
We somehow went out onto the tarmac,
got in a car and drove to the front of the line of immigration.
This guy just walked past,
everybody handed our fucking all three of our passports and they just stamp them
and we walked through.
It was just like,
what the fuck was,
that was the greatest thing ever.
And so,
um,
yeah.
And then we met the promoter and that's when I first learned that there was some
shit going down over here.
He goes,
yeah,
he goes,
I was gonna meet you here with a bulletproof vest and a,
uh,
a helmet on.
And I was like,
I was like,
oh yeah.
And then he just looked at me.
He goes,
yeah,
what's been going on over here?
I was like,
no,
cause he goes,
I'm sure you've got a bunch of texts.
I'm like,
no,
I don't want you to know this dude.
And he goes,
hey,
you know,
they,
she goes,
they shot a couple rockets,
you know,
whatever from the what,
I don't know how the fuck it works.
The guys in strip or something like that I read today was 700.
Um,
but,
uh,
it was big news.
Yeah.
So some of that stuff,
something happened in the Bruins game.
How many texts you get?
I,
yeah,
I know I did.
Yeah.
So he just kept saying that and I just joked,
we said,
dude,
I played Camden New Jersey.
I'd fucking survive that.
I think I'll be all right here.
So,
um,
anyways,
this place is fucking magical land.
Like I don't think I've,
uh,
this is just,
this is something about,
you know,
being along the Mediterranean Sea and all that and how old is polices and all
the history and all that type of stuff.
And I don't know,
I just hope I have a good show here tonight.
There's so much shit to talk about,
but let's talk about cs.
Joe.
I had to look them up because we would like,
is the Mediterranean the number of the biggest see out here and being sports
fans,
there always has to be a ranking here.
Um,
this is all body of water,
the biggest ocean Pacific than Atlantic,
then Indian than the Arctic.
We do.
We see the Arctic where we were,
we on art.
None on an Arctic was,
was on the other side.
Let's look.
We ran really high up there.
I realize how I,
oh,
hi means far up north.
Yeah.
Well that's bad.
Nobody lives higher than Santa Claus
is the Norwegian Sea does.
There's a Greenland.
See the Barents Sea beds,
the Arctic Ocean do.
We were no where near.
Okay.
I mean,
for American's we were pretty close to it.
Yeah.
I didn't realize how high up those people are though.
Even compared to Britain,
they're pretty high up.
Uh,
even with like Iceland.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
here's,
here's the rankings on of seas and oceans,
Pacific Ocean,
Atlantic,
ocean,
Indian Ocean,
and then articulation coming in fourth,
like the Nhl against basketball,
football and baseball.
Soccer,
creeping up in the battles in the oceans.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
A coral sea is number one Arabian Sea as far as size.
The South China Sea,
China,
where the fuck that is?
The Caribbean Sea and the Mediterranean Sea.
So it ranks fifth ranks fifth but number one in your hearts number,
you running your number six,
your program.
Yeah,
I mean,
come on.
Do it.
I mean out of all the C's that you could live along,
I mean,
you're talking what has the hottest women,
you got ego,
Italy,
Greece,
France,
Spain.
Through how could look at where the people on the flight over yet he,
Israel,
there were,
there was there,
there wasn't like any tens,
but there was no twos.
It was just an auto Isabella check team.
It was all second round draft picks that wanted to prove themselves.
It was,
it was,
it was a Vegas Golden Knights.
Exactly.
That's exactly what I want.
The budget you want to discard.
The women here are just reading all the cities.
Everyone's like,
you know,
Sweden had some oddities.
Love Sweden,
Finland.
Finland was amazing.
No Way.
These Israeli broads there,
they're like wonder woman.
Yeah.
And they know like that,
that Israeli martial arts,
which makes it even harder,
you know?
Oh,
absolutely.
Shit.
A bar.
They can handle it.
Well,
it's like that chicken.
It's like,
it's like the waitress on the plane.
How hot was she?
And she was like 60 years old.
She loves you,
man.
I'll tell you something about you,
Joe.
Fucking women.
Women love you the way they are repulsed by me.
I don't know about that.
I do know there's,
I don't know,
come up to you that your energy man,
they just,
they just smile.
You got him fucking smiling.
They look at me.
I fucking weird.
I everybody like I have a defensive,
standoffish vibe that I wish I didn't have it.
You know what?
I came into the world with orange hair so I'm always looking for the other
fucking shoe to drop.
You came in Joey be looking like a fucking,
you know,
I had sideburns when I was,
when I was like,
you know,
when I was,
whatever like one day old,
I had sideburns in 1969 and all the nurses would always were laughing at me and
my dad would tell me like in the uh,
whatever the booth is,
they keep the babies.
I frequently,
yeah,
it Joe,
I always forget the fucking comics name.
It was my favorite jokes of all time or just like some guys have it with women,
I don't know what it is.
They never had it,
but whatever it is,
I have the Anti Dogs,
ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
anyway,
let's,
uh,
let's get into,
let's get,
let's talk a little bit of hockey here.
Joe,
my Boston Bruins.
Um,
I've missed every second in the series being over here,
traveling and my fucking NHL Network,
feed dot working there.
They're up there.
One game away from closing out the great uh,
team that Columbus has put together.
Yeah.
With one of your,
your favorite cultures out there,
right?
Yeah.
Dry and Twitter rather than they,
this thing I can see about torts as he likes dogs.
I know.
You just can't stand that guy.
Yeah,
it's too much.
But he's doing a great job right now.
He's doing an absolutely fantastic job with,
with Columbus and you've got to give it to Barofsky that goaltender,
you know,
and he's always a regular season guy.
Play offs.
Couldn't stop a beach ball.
Now he's stopping everything.
Yeah.
And I go to,
I don't want to game seven with them.
I want to,
uh,
well I think this game sex,
I'm saying obvious shit here,
but I really want to,
I really want to fucking,
I just want to get past these guys cause I kind of feel like if they get past
us,
they might win the cup.
I,
they just got that and there that weird vibe.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just,
I'm just still so stunned that they swept Tampa Bay who just had their fucking
way with us.
The last two games that I watched with tempo,
I don't know,
like I've said a zillion times at parties,
Tampa Bay just collapsed.
So you're actually going to run into a bigger bus.
Solve teams that believe in each other as the Carolina hurricanes are next.
If you're worried about Columbus Karma,
the storm surge is calming.
Let me ask you this dude.
Is it a changing of the guard?
Cause all of a sudden it's like all these perennial,
you know,
the very least getting into the western conference that used in commerce finals,
everybody's gone.
Pittsburgh gone.
Your penguins gone.
Uh,
capital's had gone Tampa's gone.
Winnipeg Gone Vegas Nights.
I know they're not perennial,
but like what they did last year,
they're gone.
Uh,
the kings has done,
Blackhawks are out.
It's like,
it's like the lead turned upside down.
Well,
a couple of things been a couple of,
some of the fat cats just got,
had nothing to do from,
you know,
uh,
Saint Patrick's day on in lost their edge and teams that had been playing art.
Look,
it seems like the blues,
Ers,
Carolina,
Columbus,
they all had the win every game just to get in.
Are you going to call him?
The Blues is about doing a podcast or seven years in something fun to talk about
it cause they've never won the Duluth.
Here's my big gripe against the St Louis Blues actually is they've never won
anything.
And they have almost as many retired jerseys is the Montreal Canadians.
How many of these people can actually be heroes?
Some playgroup brothers.
I mean there's the guy who heads and they engage.
The guy gave him somebody to deal with like car.
Now all of a sudden he's,
his number's retired.
Come on,
I guess.
See Brett Hall.
I can see how Mcginnis I did that.
I mean really,
I mean,
right in my era.
I understand,
I understand what you said,
but my thing is like,
they never want a cup.
This not like they haven't won a cop since.
They've never want to come.
They've been in the league.
Uh,
basically they came in the league the year after.
they take me the second one is 67 and the next year was
the expansion there.
The next six they came in with us in Philly.
No,
but yeah,
so that was 67,
68.
So may police one 66 67 and they never want to fucking cop.
I don't know.
I just,
I,
I don't,
I don't hate them.
I just called him the blues or is this fun and they've never won.
So they are the blues and they kind of get a pass because American say three
like in Saint Louis where it's like nobody,
it'll have like that anger,
east coast anger and I don't really have that hockey anger,
that Patrick Division anger that Adam's division angrier than they were in the
north in the media,
like the through GM this year is having the,
has made some lucky moves.
He usually,
he's just
like,
I don't know.
I always think their GM is kind of a tool and they had an Hitchcock you,
I hate captain kangaroo.
I mean that guy.
I love the fact that it's Dallas and the blues two teams that fire Ken,
it's cock.
I call him captain kangaroo,
so I love the fact they're stolen.
They're now,
now everyone's like,
oh my God.
Bargains talking hockey click.
No,
oh no.
They're actually probably upset with me that I haven't fucking been talking to
for for the longest time.
You know,
once she had the,
well I do my brain.
I don't know what's going on my fucking brain.
I just had sun yet again.
Something that I wanted to fucking say.
You said something reminded me of something and it just goes away.
Joe,
where does it go?
Where does it go?
The last couple of years?
There's things sometimes I just can't remember.
Like I,
it takes me day,
I forget them every time.
Tracy Morgan,
I love the guy.
One of my favorite weeks ever worked with him.
There's like a sun spot in my head that I can never remember that I have to say.
Yeah.
Hilarious guy said live 30 rock to everyone.
It's like I'm playing $20,000 pyramid every time I say this
and I know it's tracing.
It's so funny.
Or like a hockey player's name,
comics like that.
And I love,
I'm not going to say the names cause I love both of them.
I cannot,
now I have both their names in my head right now.
I can say them,
but I don't want to say I just for some fucking reason it just never,
it never sticks.
It's like a,
there's a couple of words my whole life I just can't spell.
Like for the longest time I just couldn't spell restaurant,
I guess.
Couldn't spell it.
I couldn't remember where,
uh,
that's another thing to do to,
is it the older I get,
I'm realizing how fucked up my,
uh,
my brain as far as the way I look at shit yet.
You know what always fucks me up in a hotel is when you get into a shower and
you know they have like the hot and cold and it's done with the,
uh,
you know,
they'll have like a red dot on the left side and the,
and then a blue one on the right side.
So to me that means if you turn it to the right,
you get,
it's going to be cold.
But it isn't.
It's,
it's,
you gotta have the whatever.is on top.
It just never fucking,
so I'm sitting there,
you know,
I wanted to get hotter and it's getting colder and colder.
I'm standing there,
freeze my ass up going,
what the fuck?
So now whenever I go to a a shout,
cause I always guess wrong,
whenever I get to a shower in a hotel,
what I do is I just stick it in the middle for a minute and I just wait until it
gets warm and then I just turn it a little bit one way or the other.
So that's the only way they can tell.
When I stand at the stove,
to me,
the front of the stove was what everybody else considers the back.
I always look at it like I'm standing at the back of a car.
I Dunno dude.
You guys don't fucking work.
Well,
say his to stove,
right.
This table right here,
the closest part to me,
that's the back to me.
Oh Front.
The front is like,
that's the,
that's the front.
And then we'll move in towards the back.
You think you're looking at a map of a,
uh,
of a show?
Like you're buying tickets to see Metallica like yeah,
the front.
Not In the back.
Yeah.
That's how I,
I know.
I love you.
Like I'm standing behind a car,
right?
Yeah.
The thing about the showers.
Why do the only,
I think the only thing that and the fact that every airplane,
they kept the windows up the whole time.
I think the only two things I don't like about Europe is that in the fact that
showers are all death traps,
Mi,
Mi and comes to the candy.
I've almost died about four times cause you guys at your big guys,
I haven't had a problem with the size of the last doors that like,
and you have to climb over a wall and again it's taking to break into the
shower.
There's a glass door every may.
Hey,
I would do it if I was speeding up,
up,
up after ugly Americans.
Every shower is one of those showers is like you can either have the rainstorm
down or the analogs,
you know,
clean up all your crevices.
But they always put the crevice thing aimed directly where your face would be
when you turn on the lot.
I mean,
every time I laugh it gets me every time through that gotta be,
that's gotta be the fluffy from the major.
I guess I'm saying that's the best.
Like you don't even know to turn it on.
Yeah,
but I don't know.
Honestly I am,
I,
I am no idea what that fucking handheld thing is for.
Oh I do.
But you know it's a family show.
Yeah.
This is for cleaning everything out.
I Dunno,
I just put things,
but you gotta you shit.
You fucking hands.
Got To be on a washcloth to do it.
And then you got that hand and if you're taking your hand and you've got a hands
free device where you could just stand there cleaning yourself.
I thought,
I always thought it was for women.
I think you'd say.
I feel like pleasure themselves in the shower.
It is,
you know,
there's many,
many ways to skin a cat.
I'll tell you one thing though.
The other thing.
The other,
the only other thing I don't like about Europe is a lot of,
and it's funny cause I don't even drink soda anymore for three years,
but I'm offended as an American is lot of Pepsi countries.
It was a lot of Pepsi Co's,
Blah,
blah,
blah.
A lot of Pepsi countries.
Not Good.
Come on Trump.
No,
wait.
Which ones were they?
Uh,
I assume was a Pepsi country?
the first two were Pepsi countries and then we seem like we got back to then
like the regular cities.
Copenhagen was a Pepsi country.
The Copenhagen was the first time I smelled urine in the street.
And I'm like,
okay,
I'm feeling a city now.
Do filing and feeling of city.
And you know,
I saw the,
saw the rat and Sweden was next.
A house.
Think he was the,
I was thinking also to me where they're most like American cities.
I'll tell you what though.
I love what makes you feel at home.
The smell of urine and rats.
No,
but I love,
I love the concrete to trains the train system.
I love the subways.
It was great.
Uh,
walking,
I just got up every morning and walked around.
Here's,
here's this funny,
right?
We've seen millions of people in the streets,
big cities,
right?
Only one person that would be considered kind of a jerk.
That was an old guy in an airport that gave you a forum,
Shiver,
iron Mike Sharp.
And he bumped into candy and shooed me away.
Like,
get away.
Yeah.
That was this fucking guy.
We
were going through airport security and I saw the stain on what we are missing,
my daughter and everything.
I just see this guy just like lit up this old guy with his granddaughter.
I'm like,
oh,
that guy totally gets it.
He gets life.
He spoils that kid.
And it was,
it was making me feel,
seeing the joy that he had with this kid made me feel a little less,
you know,
fucking said that.
I don't know why,
but uh,
you know,
just seeing like this scene,
I,
you know,
when you're missing your kid and you see somebody who looks like they suck at
being a parent and really just fucking ruined your day,
but you actually see somebody with their kid or grants,
can you see that they're enjoying it.
It makes you feel,
I dunno,
you know,
we'll use this guys appreciate it,
right?
So all of a sudden like I'm going through the fucking security and I just,
this fucking guy like right in my,
like a crosscheck right in my base and my back and he said something like,
get out of the way,
get all the way in his language.
And I'm looking at,
I'm like,
and I'm done.
I looked behind me,
there was nobody behind me and I'm like,
what the fuck is,
what the fuck was that?
I'm looking at him and it was this sweet old guy with this kid and I'm thinking
like,
what the fuck was that about?
And then I just kind of laugh because he was old and I said to Joe,
I said to you,
I go,
that guy is fucking fucking old.
Gay just gave me a little mini forum,
shipper the back and then he,
and then you go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
he fucking shoot me awake.
He did the double hands,
like,
get out of here,
get out of the way.
And then we'd set,
tell it to club store to Kenny.
And Kenny goes,
yeah,
you pushed me to,
I think he didn't like Americans.
That's the only way I can think about it because there's one thing of being an
asshole.
But Dude,
you and club Soda Kenny or like you like the fucking,
uh,
I don't know you both like six,
three,
six,
four.
You fucking
meatheads.
Yeah,
I didn't,
the meatheads sense of like,
uh,
we lived,
we look like we're like,
we live waste,
but in the beat had said so we're just big enough in the way.
No,
I would say meat heads.
Just,
I'm aware that we didn't live like the barbarians though.
Remember that dude,
I'm fucking with you.
I don't fucking know.
I know,
but you know,
we do stand in the way though.
Where are we are big to get around?
Well,
I've been doing so well with my anger and I gotta be honest with you,
that fucking you were almost triggered.
It almost triggered you.
Yes.
Set me off where I was just like,
I am I really gonna am I really looking for this guy right now?
The bump back into an old guys like let it go below.
They always see the retaliatory try to lead as well.
I know two minutes he read mark shot you got in your head,
he got in your head at the airport.
But think of all the airports we've been in every life.
I've never been a goal score my team,
my team can handle me in the box.
You know that,
that me fighting old guide is not going to hurt
the PM's in your career.
You're alone pimps.
Oh yeah.
I'm not gonna say who,
but somebody else told us the fucking story about a,
I dunno about,
I dunno,
some buddy of his,
I'm going to make this real vague.
A buddy of his that was going through some shit with his wife,
his wife was drinking and then she got hammered and tried to hit him,
swung and miss instead of face plant on the sidewalk and fucked yourself up and
then said,
I can't believe you just did that to me and was threatening to,
uh,
do the old domestic violence they do have in the level that that fucking set me
off.
Um,
I actually learned something about myself about that and I,
I kind of figured out where that came from.
My kind of,
I grew up with a couple of relatives that did not have good relationships in
whatever their experience was.
Subconsciously,
they put it on me and I kind of,
I think I just took that in of like,
oh,
women,
fuck you over.
You gain,
you get him,
you get involved with them and then the other shoe drops and they fuck you.
I'm telling you,
Joe,
it's like I tonight somehow took that in and I walk around that and with that
energy and that's why that beautiful Israeli check was talking to you and she
looked at me,
she was talking to you like,
oh,
and go see this and go see that,
blah blah.
She looked at me,
she's just like,
is everything all right?
Take it easy,
you know?
Well,
you know what's funny was like when he wanted the person to call and missed the
version,
I'm like,
oh,
is she going to tell me the places to go to?
No,
she is not.
That was one of the funniest things ever in first class because he was so in a
mister amenities.
Whenever she goes to counties,
as she gave Kenny's last name,
Mr and then she's like Mr. Berger nations,
Mr. Barton.
And then she started talking to me.
Since then he's getting some birds you like,
what do you want?
Mercy was so upset,
but in the play they had to go,
can you please call him mister Versie?
Okay.
That's the thing.
When me and frizzy fly together,
we laughed the whole time.
We looked like two homos going on under our honeymoon.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
two guys,
you make the world believe in love.
Okay.
You see you two guys together.
You like,
you know what a cad happened for me.
This could really happen for me.
So who's your pick?
Who's your pick to go to the a Stanley Cup.
Smart shirts.
Bruins sharks.
Rolling both Thorton.
Jumbo Joe coming back,
maybe hoisting the cup and being town.
But yeah,
I had to be,
I had to get it and another
great player that we shipped out during that time because he,
you know,
and I told he's not a Bruin.
It's just like what?
What the fuck does that mean?
He's scoring goals by the goddamn bagful.
I Dunno,
I never understood that one.
They always do you know what it was?
You don't have the flyers did that thing for the longest fucking time where they
still do now that no they don't.
They don't,
but they,
they,
they did that how they want it in 7,475 they kept playing that way.
It was like they kept that high school jacket on for like the next fucking 30
years.
The billings,
the Bruins also had that big bad Bruin.
We played this,
we play a certain style.
So when we would get guys that came in who were big guys who weren't going to
sit in penalty box and they were just going to score a fucking goals,
I don't think we knew how to deal with them or at least carry send it then we're
back in the deck.
It wasn't the worst trade though for both parties concerned.
But uh,
yeah,
I had the Bruins,
I the I the ruins had the best chance of beating Tampa Bay a and W I was wrong
about that.
Uh,
Columbus did,
but I,
I,
I just think this is the sharks a year.
I think they all know that they had the right blend of youth and uh,
they got Carlson on the blue and blue line now.
I mean,
they,
they can control 45 minutes with two,
two defensemen between Burger.
But what about the Boston Slam?
I wasn't up on your proposal.
I'm writing for the Boston and slam just because of all the people that just
hate Boston.
I think it's,
I think jealousy and envy is just the worst thing on earth.
When people are jealous,
people are envious people.
It's sickening.
So seek out ways,
jealous and envious.
The way that woman was talking to you in the way she flew by me.
I hope you didn't look across the aisle.
What was so funny was I tell you,
I have to tell the story.
We have to tell the story of the,
uh,
family,
orgy,
uh,
um,
you know,
a family pool with the Holiday Inn and then at the hotel,
Oh,
where were we?
We were in Amsterdam.
That was Amsterdam,
but they ended up,
fuck band is great.
Gym downstairs,
spiral staircase down and they had this,
this pool at the spa and I brought my,
I finally remembered to bring my bathing suit and my swimming.
Douglas.
I've been swimming laps every city I've been going to.
Thanks
God.
Like we like Thorton melon at least in San with Italian filling the pool,
talking about what's going on in your life.
Like,
it's okay bill and get a couple more laps and will cause Steve,
we already did the fucking uh,
the steam room right.
And I'm thinking,
you know,
there's a men's one in a woman's one or whatever and I forgot I'll close to
Germany.
We were,
well dude,
I'm telling you they will fucking butt ass naked.
We got there and it was like a coed one till we get in there and we fucking walk
in and I look into like the,
the sauna and thought it looked like the partridge family.
It was like an entire family in there.
There was like men,
women chance all different ages and like just the lie,
I looked for two seconds and I was look,
look,
the saw a lot of skin and I just started laughing and I turned around,
I walked out,
I had to regroup and be like,
I'm not fucking going in there.
So then I saw the steam room.
So we went in there and we got in there and they had that thing turned on to
about like 72 degrees or something.
It wasn't even,
yeah,
hot enough.
It was,
it was,
it was not as hard as your grandmother's house.
Yeah.
Do,
it was,
it was fucking terrific.
And then you told me,
I said,
dude,
I couldn't look into that sauna room.
And you were like,
yeah,
there's a couple of women in there with their beavers out.
And I was just like,
I'm not,
I'm not fucking going in there.
I fucking refused to do that.
So then those,
those,
those little Italian kids came
growing up.
Gadi is Italian kids in there spraying?
Everyone was hose is urgent spreads each other.
Yeah.
It was a little,
it was a little,
it was funny how you said it though.
It was like,
we went from like the Holiday Inn and um,
you know,
Cincinnati family pool too.
Like we joined the cult in Germany.
She opened that door.
Yeah.
Like the pool and the pool was,
there was a bunch of kids in it.
There's this amazing pool and we were spoiled because there's been nothing but
like lap pools for adults.
And we got there to,
yeah.
It was like the fucking way back.
We were standing at a Howard Johnson's,
it's fucking a,
I don't know that one.
They used to have,
we used to drive down the cake when I was a kid.
But anyway,
so I ended up going upstairs and I just fucking worked out instead.
But dude,
I got to tell you right now,
that fucking bullshit when you go into a a,
a sauna in this men and women there and everyday,
but he is fucking naked.
It's like,
you know,
go join a cult.
Go fucking go,
go,
go to one of those states.
This,
I don't understand how it's like we're in a regular part of town and all of a
sudden they go to like a nudist beach,
let's say back.
That's really like a specific kind of fucking person.
Cause there was one in San Francisco.
It's Hilarious,
you know,
the Baker beach.
So I was screwing around.
So I'm like,
uh,
I'm like,
um,
I'm going to show up in the,
in mess with my girlfriend who's now my wife and be naked,
you know,
so me and my buddy counts and Kevin get as close as we,
we're walking down and all of a sudden it's like she's with a bunch of people we
work with.
No.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't really,
those days I was known to be naked way more because I drank a lot more,
well,
not a lot more,
but more.
Um,
yeah,
it just,
it was,
it was just,
uh,
you know,
there's no,
there was no reason for her to the women that just be like spread eagle.
It was like,
they could have just sat there nicely like that,
their robes on like I did.
Yeah.
I don't,
you know,
there was no,
then you go in there and then there's like this pressure because they're naked.
If you don't get naked,
then you're a fucking Weirdo.
And it's like,
no,
I'm,
I'm the sane one here.
Yeah.
No,
I kept the,
I kept it together.
I
Dunno.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
Maybe it's my fucking uptight Catholic upbringing.
Let me read a little bit of advertising here.
All right,
policy genius.
It's spring exclamation point.
The time of year when seeds grow into flowers.
Oh,
does that still actually happen?
I thought corporations owned all the fucking seats.
Uh,
and you grow up financially at least.
your family needs protection.
If something happens to you,
and that means you need life insurance.
This is the Dave,
some Manco of fucking or they're going to protect you here.
Thankfully,
policy genius makes it easy to get that financial security without the growing
plant page.
Policy Genius is the easy way to buy life insurance online.
And just two minutes.
You can compare quotes from top insurers to find your best price.
Once you apply the policy genius team will handle the paperwork and red tape,
no commissions,
no hidden fees,
just financial protection and peace of mind.
No attached and policy genius doesn't just sim simplify life insurance.
They also make it easy to compare and buy home insurance,
auto insurance and disability insurance.
So next time you stopped to smell the roses,
pull out your phone and had to policy genius.com policy genius spring is here.
Kicked it off by nipping life insurance in the bud.
It is the bud bud.
Do you have insurance life?
I got all that shit.
I got enough.
If
car insurance,
we've got common shares.
Well,
you got something.
Yeah,
well,
I guess I get cards for Chin and you've got a great car.
The cars I owned more valuable than me.
Well,
maybe you should go to policy genius and competitive over to do comparison
prices and you know what?
Your wife's going to be so happy that you did that.
She's going to get you some Sherry's berries.
Oh,
it's a fucking segue.
Mother's Day is coming up in this absolutely nothing.
Most of us wouldn't do to make sure the special moms in our life are happy.
I love how they clarified that so dysfunctional people wouldn't get offended.
It's like,
hey,
my mom,
she said your bitch.
Talk about your mom and why she deserves to be happy this mother's Day because
she's my mom.
Like,
why do I have to get into that pool?
Hate their moms?
I just done.
I mean,
you know.
Well,
I mean,
you could have an asshole mother,
eh,
every,
everyone's mom's not,
it's like,
you know,
a and viable and is nuts.
She's like Ray Romanos mom [inaudible] and funny.
But then there's women who fucking put their kids in scalding bathwater.
I mean,
come on,
come on.
Just have to make me say that in the middle of this region,
I guess.
Melted the chocolate off this strong.
I know you'd have to go that extreme.
Well,
I dance around that.
You weren't taking the bait.
Like everybody's bombs crazy.
You're making like the ones who like make Jello with the fruit in it.
Now I'm going a little further than that.
Alright.
Sherry's berries has special mother's Day.
Barry's designed for just moms that top with chocolate chips,
pink shimmers,
sugar and swizzles.
Uh,
describe how much these Gore make goodies would make this special mom in your
life.
Smile.
Well,
not my mom.
She probably would say she could make it better.
Uh,
but choose your delivery date to ensure mom gets your gifts of Sherry's Barry
exactly when you want her to and your satisfaction is always guaranteed.
Don't wait until the last spectrum and when they wouldn't do that,
she would try to figure out how you make them and then she would make them
better.
Don't wait until the last minute on this one.
Visit berries.com today to order freshly dipped strawberries starting in 1999
for the moms in your life to make mom really happy,
you can double the barriers for just $10 more.
Mother's Day is Sunday,
May 12th so visit [inaudible] dot com that's B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the upper right hand corner and enter my code burr.
That's berries.com click the microphone code burr.
Sherry's berries.
Do kick ass.
They do care.
I got to say for the record,
my mom,
she's like fun,
kind of crazy.
Excuse rural.
You're a crazy.
She's one of those.
My mom is actually totally sane.
My mom.
My mother is,
is a saint.
I've always told her your mom's mellow.
Yeah,
she is in,
she is in the Hov like she's in the express lane to go to heaven.
Um,
stamps.com me,
I'm in the breakdown lane.
stamps.com no one really has time to go to the post office.
You're busy.
Who's got time for all that traffic,
parking,
lugging all your mail and packages.
It's a real hassle man.
That's why you need stamps.com where the most popular time saving tools for
small businesses,
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the post office with therapy,
sorry,
jet lag and you get 5 cents off every class,
first class stamp and up to 40% of priority mail.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the cost for those expensive postage meters.
stamps.com is a no brainer,
saving you time and money.
It's no wonder over 700,000 small businesses already used stamps.com right now
my listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any longterm commitment.
Just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter bar.
All right.
How do you get 5 cents off of a stamp?
Well,
I mean they cost more than 5 cents,
so there you go.
It seems like a good deal though.
It is.
Especially in,
you know,
and it makes them want to write more people send out post office,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to have to make sure that my stuff gets there.
It's like,
I think I'd never done that.
Only once in my life I put a check and do an ATM,
like seeing somebody face.
Oh yeah.
You're one of those guys.
Well that's good.
Let me kind of kills the copy.
I just read that.
I'm not saying that I've said it's great deal.
All right.
Hey,
by the way,
uh,
my patrion page,
I had to shut it down because,
uh,
and for those of you who follow me on Instagram,
I'm,
I'm just,
I just don't fucking,
I'm not,
I just walk around.
what am I a fucking working for?
Meet the press or whatever,
some,
some gum shoe with some shit.
I'm not filming this shit.
I'm doing,
I'm doing this shit.
I'm doing so I suck at it.
And I felt bad like I was taking some people's money.
I just don't want to fucking do it anymore.
So we're going,
we gotta youtube all the uninformed.
So now going to be available on iTunes,
Google play,
Spotify.
You can catch up now.
New episodes to come.
Me and Joe to Rosa.
Um,
I apologize.
The people that subscribe to my page,
I started off fast.
I had a couple of helicopter videos and it just,
I just never,
I just never think to do that.
I saw fucking jet blue plane that they,
people thought they were going to crash and people had the presence of mind
during possibly the end of their life.
This.
I loved it.
Started filming like their phones were going to survive.
You fucking drop your phone up a goddamn table with no fucking case.
The screen shattered.
You're going to survive,
you're going to die,
but there's going to be a plane crash and your fucking phone's going to have the
video.
Yeah,
no patron just seems like way too much work to keep up the content.
I don't know what to give what to pay for.
I mean,
I'm not saying I was thinking what to do.
One myself,
we were going to do one for pocket off.
It's like when someone gets a free tee shirt,
what else is there?
I'm looking to walk around and if I put my morning skates on there and it's like
then people who just want to see you for free.
I just like give him,
you know like you got give him back.
Hey,
you're a man of the people.
Do you think they'd give this as a part of it?
That's comforting.
You know when you're in a near death experience to film it because now it feels
like you're so excited about the content you're going to have for your
Instagram,
that it takes you out of the fact that she could possibly,
that you're not going to be around to upload it,
that you're going to be a mortal,
everybody's gonna be like epic guy films his own death.
Um,
I don't know John,
I'm just trying to really relate to the youth here.
Let's,
let me,
let me read some of these,
I'm sorry there's a couple here Joe that um,
I I I'm gonna start with this one cause this,
hello,
this is,
this is mail time.
This is mail time.
I just want to say one thing that I thought it was interesting if you don't
mind.
I thought it was fun.
You can chime in whenever you want because I said hey are cause I didn't know if
we were going to be an APP.
I didn't know if is like considered Africa that I would knock off five
continents.
I've been to,
no,
it's Asia eight,
right.
So they told me that it's Asia,
but they pretend that they're in Europe.
You were saying they identify so that's what I'm saying.
So they're like transgender in the sense that the,
even though they are Asian,
they identify as Europeans.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's,
that gets into all that ratio.
Like white people.
I don't know.
It's weird.
It's almost like how real estate,
you know,
they do that and they try to act like,
if you really is Harlan but they call it something else.
Yeah.
Cause they don't want to scare white people or whatever.
It's like ages,
this shit.
Okay.
Well one of the greatest things I ever did was a,
that time when I did that.
Singapore,
Hong Kong,
Mumbai,
they're great fucking people.
So if you're in Asia,
I don't know why the fuck you wouldn't want to say that.
Your Asian,
that's weird to me.
All right.
Rest residents.
Scientologists hey Billy orange balls.
See the lack of respect I get here.
[inaudible] been a big fan of for years.
Loved all your specials as you podcast,
but I grew up a Scientologists.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's really Scientology.
How do you do that?
I thought they were gay.
Oh,
psychologist.
David.
Easy.
You thought Scientologists were like the closet or I note your volt that has
kids,
but other than that,
like,
I mean,
well,
it's not everybody.
I Dunno.
I think it was just like this cult.
Well,
this is the thing.
Christianity is a cult.
They,
yeah,
they,
well,
what happens is you get big enough that then you're not a cult.
You just considered a religion.
So I think like that's,
that's what Scientology is working towards is getting rid of the cult status.
Just like us as comics that work in their way.
It's that they going up,
you know,
I would say Scientology right now,
this selling out improv and they want to become a theater act like a,
you know,
Christianity.
I feel like you like cat.
The Catholicism used to be an arena act and now they're back down to theaters
with after they got caught.
Fucking all those kids.
Uh,
I dunno.
Catholicism is like,
they're like,
they're big dude.
No,
I'll do that.
It's dying in our country.
And so now they're going down to South America.
Watch out.
Everybody in South America.
Don't buy into it.
No.
I mean,
I know.
I know you could grow.
I mean really there's like families or just wear a scientologist family that's
just with adults joined.
That's all I get.
No,
but both your parents are Scientologists then you're okay.
They been around long.
I'm sorry.
It's,
yeah.
I don't know.
It's not just gay people that joined a week ago.
It's not just guys that,
it's not just guys that like wanted to move up in Hollywood.
It's that like right now what is is you have a,
you have a very Hollywood la experience with it,
so there was,
yeah,
there was a lot of that
seems like in Hollywood it's like if I wasn't gay and I don't want to do Rehab,
then they'll become a scientologist.
It seemed like the next level of a,
this sneak in the back door of a career going,
I don't know.
Whenever I look at all religions as the same where if it works via broad,
bless you,
but I think it's all bullshit.
Me Too.
I look at the same exact way.
All right.
Growing up as a scientologist,
I was looked at weird,
yelled at in the streets,
brainwashed,
you name it.
Uh,
brainwashers we sit there talking about all of our fucking shit.
heard everything.
I never understood it.
What the fuck why though?
Then one day it happened.
I look at myself in the mirror.
I had a huge piece of lettuce in my teeth all those years.
Embarrassing.
I got says,
he's saying metaphorically,
every comedian who brings up Scientology in that joke's including use says how
crazy we are.
I never said you guys were crazy.
I compared you.
I said,
you were as crazy as my religion.
I thought I showed respect when I said,
you are nuts,
right?
I Dunno.
I'm trying to make myself the hero and I'll crazy religion is,
but I don't believe that that's what you got.
What you guys think.
But does he actually thought we believed in the aliens coming down and the
spaceships and the mind reading?
I never said mind reading.
How did they know he was assigning touch industry?
Was He wearing like a,
uh,
a battlefield earth tee shirt you probably take?
Probably no,
he was in Scientology.
We
told them,
wait a minute.
Whoa.
Because if you actually thought we believed in the aliens coming down the space
ships and the mind reading,
you'd all be on fucking board.
Every one of you.
No,
I wouldn't.
That's the cabs of cabs.
That's the coolest shit ever through this.
The coolest shit ever.
Just smoking weed,
talking about it.
But if it's an actual organization and then some old trusty red edit guy telling
me this shit,
yeah,
I don't have fucking buy it now.
The other one's Barneys TV and answer them then would be on a spaceship so I
don't buy it.
Anyways.
She says,
I laugh when people say Scientology is crazy and bad and wrong.
And the only source of information on this subject is anti Scientologists who
hates Scientology.
I saw the Scientology documentary stay away.
I mean,
it's a decent point.
He's making it a,
if you thought that documentary was good,
you would love that documentary Hitler did on the Jews.
Uh,
amazing best ever.
Or that documentary
the Wiley Coyote did on the road runner.
Oh Man.
Stay away from the road run.
Most horrible burden all time.
All right,
so this guy's obviously offended and does not have any sense of humor buttons.
You can say whatever you want about the Catholic church.
I mean,
we literally tortured people into becoming a torture chamber in this hotel.
Yeah,
800 years old.
Yeah.
You're a torture chamber that they used to put on religious do.
That creeped me out and he goes see that?
And it ended at one of the little iron fucking things that you would put the
chain around,
a little hoop in the wall.
I was just like,
dude,
I don't want to be down here.
This what this is like my entertainments and other people get and it was part of
the crusade and they will fucking tortured people through.
This is the thing I,
you can say whatever you fucking like.
What about my religion?
I'm not saying that there isn't something after for this and spirituality and
all that shit.
But religion is,
is a,
is a fucking business and it's in an e.
I believe that with mine.
I don't know enough about yours.
And just out of respect that your religion is your religion.
I'm not gonna say anything about it,
but like it's pretty much,
I dunno if it was be it got blessed.
It's all organized crime.
All right?
Most people who are nervous or put off by Scientology have never read any
Scientology books.
I dub these people pussy ass bitches.
Scared little men.
Well,
I mean you sounded like a crazy person.
Why do I want to read a book now?
You just sound dumb shit about Scientology though.
It's like,
you know,
have other things to do with my life.
It's like moving.
I want to do that.
I will say this one time somebody recommended an acting class and it was the
weirdest fucking thing I ever been in.
All right,
dude.
You know what?
Now I'm going to tell this fucking story.
Cause now you're,
you get going a little too hard here because I'm gonna,
I'm gonna tell you this.
I will,
somebody,
like long,
long time ago,
we're talking billboard with fucking full head of hair long time ago,
said to me a,
uh,
because I was looking to take an acting class because I didn't have an acting
gig or anything like that and I was out in La,
you know,
it's what you're doing.
You need to get on TV and whatever dumb reason,
right?
So this person recommended this acting class.
So I go in,
you know,
acting class,
it was pretty packed too,
right?
So,
and there's a guy teaching it,
he's famous.
All right,
I'll tell you after the podcast,
it was so,
I'm like,
wow,
it's revolting blink box,
huh?
It was true Travolta.
Blink twice.
But no,
no,
no.
He doesn't have time.
He's too busy crushing it.
So I fucking go in there and they go,
okay.
And the guy goes to start the class.
He goes,
okay,
does anybody have any news they want to announce?
And some of the class raises their hand and they're like,
yeah,
I just booked two episodes on Jag,
like zone a long time ago.
This dude.
And when I tell you the whole class,
like you would've thought somebody just fucking hit three point and to win an
NBA championship.
They all just go
like fucking crazy.
And I was just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Three other people announced,
oh,
I got something on friends or fucking everybody loves Raymond screaming like
that.
So then they go,
all right ladies,
we have a couple of people auditing the class today.
They go,
we got pleased wise,
you stand up comedian,
please welcome Bill Barr Dude.
And they cheered that loud again.
Like my face turned red.
It was fucking like fucking crazy.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
So during the,
the break of the class,
I go in to meet them,
to talk to him.
I'm auditing the class is what they call it.
You're checking out and the guy's just going like,
you know,
we have our own security,
we have our own,
everything was our own,
blah,
blah.
And I jokingly said,
Jesus Christ,
they feel like I'm joining a cult.
And he sort of looked at me.
It was,
I was like,
what the,
you know,
so what happened?
So I ended up,
and I talked to the guy during the break,
the famous dude,
and he says,
look at me.
He goes,
well,
is that a little much in the beginning was a little much,
and I was looking at him was like,
it was pretty intense dude.
So I ended up leaving and I,
I ended up,
I told the story to so many,
they will laugh and they go,
where did you go?
And I told them,
and they go build that Scientology.
I go get the fuck out of here.
And then these fucking creeks for like a week kept calling me and like,
dude,
it was freaking me out.
Like they was stocking.
It was a fun,
was supposed to be an acting class and these fucking guys wouldn't leave me
alone.
I finally had to get like erm with them and be like,
dude,
I'm not going back.
And the guy goes,
we lost Ya.
Yeah,
Dude.
So fuck you man.
Fuck you.
Like,
dude,
I gotta take something like the,
I was like legit,
uncomfortable.
Like I got to the point where like,
I felt like,
I'm like these motherfuckers following me around.
Yeah,
you do.
Like in San Francisco,
they'd have chicks that go,
hey,
you want to take your personality test?
I'll go sit in a booth with you for 20 minutes.
And then all of a sudden it's like they tried to get you to become
Scientologists,
but I don't know why.
Like I don't want to sound stupid.
I like reading books,
but are say,
well,
I'm just like,
why don't you read a book?
It's like,
why don't,
why do I want to read a book about that Shit?
Listen,
here's the thing,
Joe.
Having said all that,
what they do,
and that is way less than the inquisition or any of that other shit.
However,
it's still all unacceptable
fucking behavior as far as I'm concerned.
And I'm entitled to that.
So dude,
I respect the fact that you are Scientologists.
You want to do that shit.
God bless you people.
You want to go to fucking church people over here?
Whatever the fuck you guys want to do.
I don't give a fuck.
Just,
I just just respect me that I,
I don't,
I don't want to,
I don't want to be a part of it.
I just don't want to be a part of it.
I just want to be a fucking,
do you know what my new religion is right now,
Joe?
The new queer eye for the straight guy on Netflix because they've now taken it
to the point that they don't just,
you know,
find straight guys that dress like us
trying and help us out.
They actually help people's lives.
Like I saw them.
They helped out these two sweet older women that they were running their dad's
barbecue joint in fucking Kansas City.
Not only did they do,
we'll make over their clothes.
They got their teeth fixed,
they got their hair done.
Then they fucking redid their whole barbecue place without ruining it.
They just updated it and then they also got their secret barbecue sauce.
Think they found a factory down the street that would jar it.
They could sell it.
So it's like a,
so it's like a bar rescue and queer eye for the straight guy.
Yeah.
But you know,
when I watch bar rescue,
there's something about when they go in there and they're just gagging because
of puts those people in like morons.
These people just like needed help.
I feel,
I don't know.
Everyone's bar seemed like a better place to drink before Taffer gets there.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's all free drinks and chicks taken off their clothes.
They'd tap her shows up and it's like,
yeah,
I don't need a mint.
Julep
yeah,
I went that broad top was giving me a favor.
Give me a shot and a beer.
Well,
I just watched one episode of that,
the new queer eye that Kansas City,
when I watched it with me when we were in Iceland,
it literally made me want to be a better person.
Like I'm like all we do is bitch about rich people and fucking politicians and
all of this shit and religion and all of that.
And like me,
while we can all be helping each other out,
uh,
on,
on the bottom.
And then then fuck all these people.
It's just like,
and maybe I don't know what I'm going to do.
Probably nothing because I'm a selfish cunt,
but it made,
you know,
it's such a good shot.
Made me think of being about a good being a good person.
Right.
That's a step.
It's his first.
Yeah.
I was going to start singing that Michael Jackson song,
but it's a bad time to do that.
All right.
The man in the mirror.
Okay.
All Dad.
Hey Billy billionaire,
give him seven 70%.
I don't even know what that means.
Like cause I was bitching that,
you know,
they should look at the 20 trillion on tax US dollars and the fucking Caribbean
rather than fucking going after newly rich fucking college kids who invented an
app and had the audacity to be worth more than 10 million bucks.
Uh,
my boyfriend and I have been together nearly four years and the baby talk is
starting to get more serious on his part.
Oh,
I've never really wanted children.
In fact,
I hate most kids,
but I am somewhat open to the idea.
Oh Geez,
you're all over the road here.
The problem is that he is 46 and I am 28.
Well yeah,
that was going to be a problem.
His balls or dre and up over there I can see myself wanting a kid later maybe in
five to 10 years.
But with him being so old,
I'm not sure we have that kind of time though.
Uh,
you talk about being an old dad all the time and the podcast and while it's
funny,
I can see where it's also terrifying.
Yeah.
Like am I going to die before I get this bird flying here?
Uh,
by the way,
uh,
good on you for getting fit and healthy.
Uh,
we started going to the gym and eating healthy a few years ago.
Our only problem is a little weekend binge drinking.
He also hits the Adderall hard at those times.
Oh boy.
Obviously that panics me when considering having children.
Other than that,
we make a small team.
We split bills,
travel and have individual hobbies.
Somehow the age different hasn't been a problem except with the baby talk.
Should I pull back on the fear and go for it?
Try to wait until I feel ready,
which could be never tell them to adopt another dog.
Thanks in advance.
And if they try to take 70% fight then to the death cheers.
Um,
Bill.
all right.
My opinion
and you don't want to,
she didn't want to hear my up and,
all right,
let's say you guys don't have a kid.
You're gonna ruin your life.
She needs a kid.
He can find somebody else.
Route 28.
You got another 10 years.
You love travel.
You love this.
You love that.
It changes everything.
If you're not ready to have a kid,
do not bring a kid into this one
world.
Yeah.
I look at it like a,
if you love this guy,
you know,
I don't know.
I've seen not,
not,
it's been nothing but positive having a kid for my myself.
I'm not saying you're not saying it's not positive.
Um,
but if you're not on the same page,
that's kind of a big thing.
And that guy doesn't have a lot of time.
Uh,
I dunno.
I guess Tony Randall,
the Mick Jagger had one of those 70 stuff.
Let me not together.
I mean,
I love my daughter everything,
but your life changes and it seems to me that you're still young.
Yeah.
And you want to,
and you're traveling and you're doing this and you're doing that.
And it's like,
that ends.
I,
but I also look at like 28.
It's a great age to have a fucking kid.
I mean,
you,
you kicked fucking graduates college right around the time you're 50.
Then you're going to get to be a grandmother or grandfather.
You get to see that.
We'd get the fucking give people four.
I'm shippers and they don't do anything in the fucking airport that this,
listen,
this Biz,
like any big decisions,
there's,
um,
there's like,
you know,
this ups and downs.
Just get the kid in the old fashioned way.
Fuck around.
And if you get pregnant,
it's a miracle.
If you don't,
you don't.
All right.
What's the advice that I ever send advice?
Don't listen to either one of us.
All right.
Need some advice,
buddy.
Billy baldness.
I Love U podcast.
Now he's [inaudible].
Right,
thank you.
Uh,
but ask us just to decide.
I'm in some shit.
So I've been dating this girl for almost two years now and everything has been
great up until about four months ago.
She is non-binary.
What does that mean?
Uh,
that's,
that's above my pay grade.
Hang on a second.
I gotta look that up.
That's one of them codes for like gay but not gay or whatever.
Yeah,
that's one of those ones who take dresses up differently but means to be
somebody else.
But
yeah.
All right.
That went to gender queer Wikipedia.
What is not by a non non binary gender is an umbrella term to describe any
gender identity that does not fit into the gender binary of male or female.
Okay.
Like I said,
nice to try and do the math on that.
So yeah,
I'm not good in Algebra either.
Wait,
[inaudible] my daughter's math tutor to tote.
I don't give a fuck if I'm looking up shit like this or just the definition of a
word.
Then there's always like another 20 things you have to look up.
Dude.
I looked up this stupid patriots and Mitchell and ness coat like fucking four
months ago.
They won't leave me alone.
I'm not buying it.
Fucking fluff it up with the ads.
You think he'd give up after you Google?
Not Gender by Nick.
Maybe.
Maybe he doesn't want a patriots jacket.
All right.
Now you ready to get them off your trail?
Nonviolent.
Various gender is an umbrella term to describe your identity as not fitting into
any gender.
Binary.
Male and female.
Non Binary gender also sometimes referred to as gender queer.
People may for exit and I don't understand gender queer.
I thought queer was offensive,
but if you,
if it's part of a bigger word,
it isn't.
For example,
identify.
Okay.
[inaudible]
as having no gender fall on a gender spectrum somewhere between male and female
identifi.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
I,
I think I'd get that now.
That just means like people look at you to look at you naked.
You're a dude,
but you don't feel like a dude.
Right?
Oh Lord.
I know we could.
A,
we could never sound dumb right now.
Let's just follow that this high since she's non binaries.
So she has no real sexual preference and she's had had a female friend that she
dated in high school.
Does that mean this?
Why did he just say she's cool?
[inaudible]
I like not by Neri chicks.
That's my kind of chick.
No,
you know,
that's what they were not learning new words.
You learn something every day.
I look at that
[inaudible]
all right.
Uh,
so she is non-binary says she has no resection private.
She's had a female friend that she dated in high school and it was on and off
from what I understand.
But this person moved to California years ago and moved back to our state like
six months ago and that's when the problem starts.
I had no issue it dude,
you gotta somehow.
No,
you gotta get in there.
Oh my goodness.
You got to get an idea.
I had no issue with it until we see one of my girlfriend asked me if I would
mind if she got a girlfriend,
but I'm not cool with that.
We talked somewhat about it and she gets irate every time we talk.
Last night she you wrote cute.
She cut basically all her hair off and all I can see is get friend now what food
,
this is like the most important part of the sentence.
On top of that she's been posting nonstop about gay stuff.
Normally I wouldn't care but they also snapchat each other at all times of the
day and she's gotten very private about her phone.
I mean Jesus Christ.
Do you have any more red flags?
Seat knee,
which lends me that she walked around with a tee shirt that said not failing
Dick Right now.
I mean it's,
yeah,
she's,
this is a wrap dude,
which leads me to believe some shit is going town.
She says she doesn't want to leave me but also won't budge with my requests on
them taking less on changing platforms.
Listen Dude,
what's going on here is because she doesn't identify is she's kind of leap
frogging over with political correctness that she's going to go fucking have sex
with somebody else.
When she's,
is she in a committed relationship and you have an open relationship,
then I guess you'd have to roll with this.
But if you guys are in a committed relationship,
she,
she goes out and gets with a guy or a woman that's not cool.
Like,
dude,
you got to like,
I would get out of this.
She invited,
she lays him in though.
Wait,
he's the one that said,
no,
wait,
I missed that part.
Well,
I think up there somewhere,
eh,
Santa Claus lives,
she's nonbinary and she's had a female friend,
blah,
blah.
No,
on and off.
But this person moved to California.
I had no issue with this until recently.
My girlfriend asked me if I wouldn't mind if she got a girlfriend,
um,
that,
that will,
uh,
ice like him.
Well,
am I going?
Am I be going to be part of that folk?
Excuse me.
I was wearing,
I thought you said that.
She said,
listen,
jump.
Don't let your fantasy get in the way of what these people actually say.
Anyway.
Also also to throw a wrench in everything we have.
We have an apartment together and we are both on the lease.
I'm kind of fucked because I have no family out here and just one friend I
initially moved out here for,
but he got a lady and turned his back on me about a year ago.
What you got a lady to do?
What are you talking about?
Any advice?
Please keep up the content.
My bald brother.
All right.
This is what I would do,
dude.
Like um,
yeah,
I would just get out of this fucking thing.
And you're both on the lease so you know she wants to have a new girlfriend over
ladder.
Who gives a fuck?
And this is the thing,
dude,
I would break her,
I'd break up with her and then just be,
just be fucking cool.
All right.
Don't get involved in.
But then you know what's going to happen is they're going to mind you to get the
fuck out of there.
But I would actually work on my life more.
He can't tell me.
Wherever the fuck do you live in?
Does not a place that you can
find on your own.
You know what I would do with the way she just said,
fuck this,
I'm getting a girlfriend and cut her hair.
She's just doing what the fuck she wants to do.
Then I would be like,
fine.
What I would do,
I go,
I would go out Madrigal well,
Al just gets the whole fucking thing done.
And then just hands them a box full of stuff and be,
here's your stuff.
We're broken up.
I would go fucking get another apartment.
All right.
And uh,
one day while she's at work,
I'd take a day off from work.
I'd get a buddy,
I move all my shit out,
and then that would be it.
And a,
and I had to call and say,
listen,
we need to talk and she's going to come home and be like,
where's all your stuff?
I said,
it moved into an apartment because we're breaking up.
And then she's going to get mad.
She's going to say,
you're a coward,
you're a pussy.
And it's like,
no,
no.
I'm not going to fucking stay here while you mentally fucking torture me.
Okay.
You're doing what the fuck do you want to do?
You know?
So that's good advice.
Yeah,
I'm doing what the fuck he needs to get out.
Yeah.
Get out of it.
Because she obviously is saying we're done.
Yeah.
And I think that she's leaning,
I mean,
what I can't get,
not,
not the gay part of it.
What I can't get past is that you're in a fucking relationship and she's going
to start banging somebody else like,
yeah,
this is what the fuck I'm doing.
If you were to say that I'm going to start banging another woman,
is it okay if I get a girlfriend?
I don't think she'd be cool with that.
So I mean,
I don't know all the parameters of that,
but like,
you know,
if you're with a woman,
if she starts banging another woman or a man than,
I don't know whether your,
your relationship is at that point,
she didn't invite you in your,
she's basically cheating on you to your face.
Yeah.
But just because you ask is that,
is that,
I'm going to try that with my wife.
Is it all right if I get a girlfriend in the sun?
All right.
Sex with my feeling very binary.
Yeah.
Whoa.
My God.
Notify you via an area.
If I say my urinary and then I just get my new girlfriend and dress like a dude,
then to wait on like a technicality.
[inaudible] my wife bought me an apology.
Like if I bang the new chick.
All right.
Sex with my wife.
So I am 36 years old and I had been with my wife since I was 19 my wife is one
year younger than me.
Okay,
so she's 35 we have three children.
1510 and three.
I mean,
look at this guy.
This guy's going to be a great grandfather.
I'm jealous.
We only have sex on average about twice a month.
Dude,
that's amazing.
If you have three fucking kids,
you've been together that long.
Yeah.
This guy's doing Greg's killing it.
He's killing it.
It's been like this on and off since we had kids.
I met to the point now where I don't even make a move.
I can't stand the rejection.
So I'll topman the fuck up,
man.
You got to see them.
You got to see the funny,
they'll hilariousness in it.
And then the patheticness when he did grab your laptop and go once and porn,
hey,
welcome to the fraternity.
Uh,
so I just waited until she makes the move.
But I get in a very bad mood after a week without sex.
Oh,
Jesus.
The man,
the man has no hands.
Yeah.
Rob went out,
uh,
from one out,
go smoke a cigar.
Uh,
she will ask what's wrong?
I just replied,
nothing.
Well,
that's your fault.
You got to communicate.
We haven't very good relationship with the exception of sex.
I get to a point where I'm actually thinking of leaving her over this,
but I love my children.
What should I do?
All right.
You're not going to leave.
Here's the deal.
You have to just,
you got to tell her how important sex is.
All right?
And you got to tell her that you get in a bad mood.
She does.
She's not taking care of you on some level,
but this was one of these things with these modern day women where it's just
like,
you know,
if they're not getting what they need,
they can tell you that you have to do all of these fucking things.
But you know,
if,
if you're like,
I dunno if you ask them to do anything that's considered,
you know,
taking care of you nowadays.
Like I won't even bother with this conversation.
Yeah.
No,
but you know,
as sad as it sad is a mediocre hand job can be sometimes that's all you need.
Maybe,
maybe,
maybe.
No,
he doesn't have to be this full law and extravagance.
But maybe,
maybe once or twice or more a month she could pop into the quick 10 minute
handy,
you know?
I can't tell you though.
You can't try to get her motor running though.
Yeah.
Because sometimes women just went,
okay.
It's like,
you know,
it's like another chore.
It's like,
I'll drop you off and go do something else.
so then you just need that other hand.
No,
it's I gotta I gotta be,
I gotta be honest.
Like it's,
it's,
it really is fucking ridiculous.
Like the amount of complaint and women do,
but the way a husband is treated through,
like,
I always say like when you first meet your wife,
you'd like the starting quarterback on the team and by the time you get fucking
married,
you get treated like you're on the taxi squad.
Like,
like you,
you never even won a championship ever.
Well that's exactly right.
Before like w four you have a kid like your Duke and the number one seed.
And then now my dog is like a 70 [inaudible] now my daughter.
And now my is like Wichita state.
I'm in the nit,
dude.
Unless I get the kid comes first.
That's what I'm talking about is like the,
the,
the way,
somewhere along the line you just start looking at yourself like when did I
become the PA of this family?
And they'll go grab us some coffee.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't fucking,
I,
you know,
that's,
that's one of the,
I gotta be honest with you dude.
All these bitch moaning and complaining that all these women are doing
specifically white women,
which is just inherently hilarious.
Um,
is,
is I really just like,
I don't,
I don't even know where to fucking begin on this one because every fucking guy
that I talked to who's married is really in the same situation.
And I think it's why guys are so funny is because our,
our situation is funny.
It's like your,
your,
your status versus they're complaining.
You would think that they were living the way that we're living.
It doesn't even,
it's like you're living in like this alternate universe.
Like sometimes you want to be like,
wait,
you're complaining,
you're tired.
Like I dunno,
I,
I to just say I'm a terrible husband,
but my wife doesn't really complain.
My wife has no other complaints.
She,
she's,
she's really known the components.
Jesus,
you're a much better husband than me.
So I'm sure my wife has her complaints.
No,
no,
I'm not even saying that.
You know what I'm talking,
I'm not talking about my wife and playing.
I'm talking about all this fucking complaining that is going on with women right
now.
And it's just like,
like when,
when they get fucking married for the most fucking,
it's like,
I'm trying to think of a guy that I know who's actually even remotely running
his household.
I just don't,
I just don't see it.
It's like what they want.
And if they don't get what they want,
then you're gonna have to deal with their emotions for three days.
So you just like,
subconsciously you just start giving into it.
Okay.
Which is how the thing works,
which is fine.
So I don't understand what all the fucking complaining is about,
but evidentaly evidently,
cause they only got the right to vote a hundred years ago.
They're lives are fucking horrific.
Um,
girl,
I do,
I get to bring up the potato famine.
A girl kissed another guy.
Oh Jesus.
Here we go.
A I neri broad.
Hey,
uh,
Billy,
totally red nuts.
I like how you want to use your new fucking
very broad.
I think this is a great one.
I love it.
No,
but that is,
she said she kissed another guy so she wouldn't be bothered with that.
She's like,
oh,
sorry.
I know you get that dyslexia blend them blinds.
Okay.
Oh,
the heat?
No.
Yeah.
You're going to get her old friend kissed another guy.
Alright.
Not non-binary.
Ooh,
they're right on the fucking,
we're out in the edge of society.
No.
Those other letters at the end of the LBG.
What does that one queer nation.
Genderqueer.
All right.
There's another one issue
in that I can never remember the bravos sports to remember it.
All right.
Just want to say I have a lot of respect for you,
eh.
Thank you.
Anyways,
I'm a freshman in college and I live on the same hall as my girlfriend.
The other night.
A bunch of the people on our floor,
we're drinking.
We all got plastic.
One thing leads to another and someone proposes the idea of spin the bottle.
I'm not stoked on playing,
but whatever,
I guess.
All right.
There's your first mistake.
You didn't validate what you were feeling.
Kissing a few dudes and some girls that I don't want to kiss his.
Evidently how my night is going to go.
Well,
you have to kiss the guys.
Yeah.
That doesn't sound right.
Every,
every time.
It's a different world out there,
Joe.
Every time it lands on me,
I'm doing the tight lip shit as to not upset anyone because that like seemed
like the right thing to do,
which are the guys kiss the guys too,
which is crazy.
My girlfriend,
however,
is straight up lip locking,
kissing dudes.
No tongue or passion or anything,
but still I felt weird about it.
Yeah.
Later that night she cried to me gap,
so now you feel like the asshole and assured me that it didn't mean anything,
but I just can't get the image of her kissing this other dude out of my head,
nor should you.
She would never cheat on me.
I know that,
so I'm probably just being a posting.
Any advice would be appreciated.
Here's some advice.
Don't play spin the bottle with the check he had fucking feelings with with
other guys.
There is no wrong.
Yeah,
it's like a worst game of spin the bottle ever.
Hey,
here's my girlfriend than some dudes.
You're always going to come,
you're always going to lose.
There's always like,
you're always going to hit the balls be a win for you.
So if you find the one hot chick you kind of like on that floor,
then your girlfriend's going to be pissed.
Why would you play that?
All right,
so here's the thing,
dude,
I can tell you this right now.
If it was the other way around and she felt that she would have cried either way
and she would have felt upset about it and you,
you would have had to validate her feelings on it,
okay?
But because now it's all about their fucking feelings here.
I'm so fucking JD,
dude.
It's going to be all about fuck you do.
This is what you feel and let her cry all the fuck she wants.
This is what you feel and he can't get past it.
Fucking break up with her.
But here's another thing too.
You fucking,
you fucked up in the beginning,
okay?
And this is the life lessons.
You were not cool with it and you didn't,
but you seem like a shutdown dude.
We just like,
well,
I'm just going to go along with this even though I don't like this.
So now you turn around in a way,
you know something.
Wait,
I changed this because you acted like you were okay with it and now you're not,
and now you're judging her.
So now I actually,
you know something you fucked up here,
sir.
I'm just going to give it to you straight like a man.
You didn't feel like you weren't comfortable with it and you didn't fucking say
anything.
And then you sat back and you let her do shit you weren't comfortable with and
now you're giving me grief over it.
So now you know something.
I actually validate her.
Tears took me a minute,
took me awhile to,
I had to get there.
I had to get there,
validate her tears and I will say this,
she's a chick,
your date and on your floor and your freshman year of college,
get over it.
Move along.
Don't put too much into her.
You gotta.
You gotta live your whole life.
Yeah,
it's a bad thing again with the same floor.
That's a bad situation anyway.
When you know it's like it's,
it's going to go bad and joy.
The joy the moment you had move along the sophomore year.
And try not to date someone on your floor Banger,
but don't fucking dater.
I'm at sage advice.
Joe Barton,
nick,
everybody.
Rose Bowl,
tailgate legend,
absolutely crushed it over here in Europe.
And we're going to go walk along the boardwalk here around in Israel.
Tinder,
the board.
Walk down by the Mediterranean Sea.
Sorry,
I can't sing.
All right,
go bro.
And wrap it up tonight.
I hope.
Uh,
that's it.
And thank you to everybody.
The bottom of my heart.
Everybody who showed up,
ridiculous amount of people showed up on this tour or I want to thank them too.
And I mean,
just as the opening act,
you guys trigger me fucking amazing.
Everybody loved Europe.
Everybody.
Yep.
And we're going to finish strong tonight here in Tel Aviv.
Sick.
Thank you for the whole tour,
man.
Thank you.
And thank God Clemson and Kenny for treating me the best.
Oh,
either the bath caddy is the best.
He is a prince.
He's like the Prince of Europe.
That's right.
All right,
guys,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.